jean pierre sueur comment réagissez vous
à ce nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère benalla qui met cette fois ci en
cause matignon déjà il ya quelques jours
vous parliez d'une affaire qui était
grave très grave à ce que désormais on
peut parler d'une affaire d'état jeudi
que cette affaire est très grave
pourquoi parce que le fonctionnement
d'une personne alexandre benalla eu à
entraîner un grand nombre de
dysfonctionnements non seulement à
l'elysée est maintenant à matignon c'est
ce que l'on découvre on découvre eu des
des choses des éléments liés à une
personne qui travaille pour la sécurité
à matignon en chef de la sécurité du
noir mais je ne peux rien en dire
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'il
ya une enquête je crois de justice la
justice s'est saisie elle-même de ce
sujet cela n'allait pas jusqu'à parler
de la sarre d'être là un de vos
collègues cela ne relève pas du champ de
notre commission
mais pour revenir je ne sais pas si
c'est une affaire d'état au pas une
affaire d'état c'est pas le sujet c'est
une affaire très grave
pourquoi elle est grave parce que
beaucoup de gens dans différentes
sphères de l'administration ont
considéré que monsieur benalla étaient
investis d'un pouvoir tels qu'ils se
sont mis à tous dysfonctionné vous
comprenez tu as à vox imiter je peux
vous expliquer le téléphone portable je
peux vous expliquer ses fonctions par
rapport à la sécurité je peux vous
expliquer son port d'armes
je peux vous expliquer ces passeports
volant qui reviennent qui repartent avec
cetera bon je peux vous expliquer
l'ambassadeur du tchad dont monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères nous
dit qu'il lui a dit ah ben non je ne
sais pas prévenu que monsieur ben alla
est venu monsieur benalla est reçu par
le président de la république du tchad
pendant une heure et demie et personne
n'était au courant
écoutez c'est incroyable autrement dit
il y à toute une série de choses
qui ne fonctionne pas normalement parce
que on prête sans doute une un pouvoir
ou une protection des prérogatives à
monsieur benhadda jean-pierre c'est ça
le problème tout cela c'est dans les
mains d'un justice donc cela n'est pas
du ressort de la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale mais est ce que la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale ne
pourrait pas d'ouvrir un nouveau volet
nouvelle convention dont jeunes sur les
dysfonctionnements à matignon sur les
dysfonctionnements mais on honore je ne
dis pas ça je ne dis pas que tout cela
relève de la justice
tout ce que j'ai dit avoir à votre micro
relève de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire et nous n'allons
absolument pas tomber dans le panneau
que nous entendu quatre membres du
gouvernement pas moi qui nous ont dit
quand on voulait auditionné monsieur
védrine a mais ce n'est pas dans votre
compétence etc
non il y a deux instances il y à la
justice qui fait son travail elle
condamne elle juge et éventuellement
elle condamne il y à nous qui un
cherchons la vérité
on a déjà beaucoup d'éléments évaluons
les dysfonctionnements les métaux à plat
pour un nombreux ils sont nombreux et
faisons des propositions pour que ça ne
recommence pas nous faisons notre
travail et le fait que la justice fasse
le sien ne n'enlève rien aux nôtres
c'est ce que nous explique avec mireille
jourda et philippe bas inlassablement et
c'est une question de fond ou bien on
considère que l'article 51 alinéa 2 de
la constitution doit s'appliquer
c'est à dire que nous contrôlons le
gouvernement et nous évaluons les
politiques publiques donc la sécurité du
chef de l'état qui est une politique
publique
ou alors on considère qu'il n'y a aucun
intérêt à appliquer la constitution et
dans ce cas c'est très grave donc nous
appliquons la constitution comme c'est
comme c'est inscrit dans la constitution
mais comme c'est normal dans la
république française et nous sommes
extrêmement vigilants rigoureux nous
n'avons rien d'autre dans la tête que de
dire la vérité de mettre à jour tous les
dysfonctionnements
et de faire ça ne se renouvelle pas bien
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction
madame tam
merci beaucoup